there's one piece of advice for for
young people in their
late teens and early 20s is that uh
if you do things that you think are
going to be fun in a healthy way
then it'll often lead you down the right
path because i think most people when
they're
positive and happy and enjoying
themselves tend to be more successful
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc found in silicon
valley
in partnership with lomi tech and
sponsored by hippo insurance
touring upward labs and hillel at
stanford investing and advising
meet alex oppenheimer alex's background
is in mechanical engineering at stanford
investment banking in morgan stanley and
then at nea working on early stage
software investments
while at nea he became an expert in the
sas business model
and spent significant time with the
portfolio companies on key strategic
operational initiatives
in addition to making investments he has
been able to leverage his network and
skill set to gain access to great early
stage companies as well
so decided to also raise money for a
small venture fund
alex oppenheimer thank you for joining
me on 20 minute leaders how are you
i'm doing well thanks for having me
thank you for being here you're in
jerusalem right now right
i am i have uh i've been in jerusalem
basically for a year now in the same uh
same office so
but there's it's probably the best place
to be so
no complaints i i love it and you're
actually your journey doesn't start in
jerusalem it starts from marine right in
california
and you've gotten a chance to be you
know spend meaningful time both on the
west coast and menlo park in stanford
but also on the east coast with nea
now in jerusalem with a yeshiva in the
middle in israel
really on an extraordinary journey of
both from
you know an intellectual perspective
getting all these different skill sets
from mechanical engineering at stanford
to more of
finance both from home and
also working at morgan stanley and then
nea now
an investor and advisor so alex i can't
think of
anything better than to ask you to just
walk me through
you know your life a little bit and
we'll touch on some key areas that
i'm really excited to dive in and really
get into the you know the
entrepreneurial mindset of
what made you decide what you did and
what are some insights that i can then
take
on with me as a young entrepreneur on my
own journey
absolutely so i guess i mean i will say
at the end i don't feel like i ever
really became
entrepreneurial or an entrepreneur at
all until i moved to israel
so that that was a big step for me to
take it there but going back to the
beginning and even kind of like i guess
the prologue
uh both my parents are from queens new
york
my dad's parents are holocaust survivors
and
uh they moved to california to marin
county in
1978 and have been there ever since so i
grew up in marin
but always spending time going to uh
going to new york to visit my
grandparents
and uh it's actually funny when i
started at stanford
a lot of people thought i was from new
york which is like
not normal because half the school's
from california so
uh but for whatever reason i i've exuded
that and so i i guess that kind of
explains some of my journey east
so um i grew up my my dad's a cfo in
silicon valley's
and he always did an amazing job of
teaching me and including me from a
young age
and things that were going on from you
know ipos to companies and
stocks and everything in between and uh
and that's really kind of how my journey
started at the same time i was always a
tinkerer and uh when it came down to it
i had the opportunity to go to stanford
and they did
and it was an amazing experience as i'm
sure you've experienced in the last
couple years
and i studied mechanical engineering and
people
since have asked me why i chose to go to
stanford and
why i chose study mechanical engineering
and the answer is actually very simple
it's just um what i thought i would have
the most fun doing
and i think that there's one piece of
advice for
for young people in their late teens and
early 20s
is that if you do things that
you think are going to be fun in a
healthy way uh
then it'll often lead you down the right
path because i think most people when
they're
positive and happy and enjoying
themselves tend to be more successful
and so
i was the great beneficiary of that at
stanford and studying mechanical
engineering getting to
you know it's a very hands-on program so
we're in the machine shop building stuff
um you know working in teams doing
problem sets until the middle of the
night
and uh had a great great experience at
stanford
i'll i'll accelerate a little bit so
didn't go far after graduating from
stanford worked at morgan stanley at
menlo park
uh you know obviously the highlight
there was working on the facebook ipo
uh did a whole bunch of other stuff that
most people probably would have never
heard of
uh but uh everyone's heard of of
facebook and and the ipo in 2012 so that
was most of my first year
um within i can't just impass that your
your
your attention stanford you're going
you're in menlo park and morgan stanley
you're
working now on facebook's ipo you're
you're holding a position that
you know thousands of millions of others
would love to have that exp that
extraordinary experience of taking like
helping take that humbling public from
and then from an investor's perspective
a third party perspective tell me a
little bit about what's that like
you know being thrown into the deep end
and and managing both a lot of
responsibility but also
you know quickly having to accelerate
your understanding into the market into
you know how the big players do it you
know getting to experience
one of the craziest ipos that that we
have until today
well i'll i'll kind of start that with a
story so the
the facebook team when i was at morgan
stanley was really only five people
it was the managing director the
executive director and associate and two
analysts
and that was really the whole team that
that was covering facebook i mean they
were covering facebook long before i
started but
when when i started um and i got pulled
onto the team after three weeks
at morgan stanley and it was one of
those moments where like kind of
not quite the drama of like your life
flashing before your eyes but when my
staffer said
hey you worked with this person on this
they want you to join the the facebook
team
it was kind of like this is a you know
this is an opportunity i have to jump on
this will be a story that i'll tell
you know for the rest of my life
probably and uh obviously
it has been and it was an it was a very
interesting experience and i think that
one of the
conclusions of it is that like there
really is no
there aren't shortcuts like the way that
we
ended up being lead left on that deal um
and the way that it all worked out was
really just you know
hard work and some creativity and i give
i give michael grimes that morgan
stanley a ton of credit
you know when i think the last time he
was in the news was you know it said oh
he was uh
an uber driver in order to get the uber
ipo
and anyone that worked with him or knows
him was like yeah obviously
like how else would you do it you know
and it's just you know don't think
you're too high and mighty to do
anything
you know put your head down and and
really understand and show that you care
and um and be just a little bit creative
and it really goes a long way
amazing i i love that and i think that
one of the things that we'll see a
pattern throughout this conversation is
this idea of jumping on opportunities
and getting excited about them
and and you know being humble enough to
accept that you know while there is
somewhat of this like very fairy tale
trajectory of of where
you think you need to end up or in every
point in the road to reach that big
milestone it's that's not actually how
it works it's about those humble those
real experiences those tangible
experiences
of being that uber driver to understand
the magnitude of an uber ipo i think
that's exactly the lesson that i'm that
i'm trying to gain
through this show so take me take me
forward a little bit you have some
decisions that you have to make
part of them uh you know are are you
know obvious some of them are not so
obvious
yeah and and frankly uh very few things
i think seem obvious when you're in the
middle of them
i you know i grew up in a very you know
like
i guess i would say stereotypical upper
middle class
jewish family in uh in marin county and
it's very
very intense you know i went to prep
school i went to stanford i worked in
banking
and uh you try to do all the things that
you're supposed to do
and open all the doors and keep every
door open and
one of the kind of ideas that i've i've
recognized is that
you know at a certain point you have to
walk through a door
and it's a very hard thing for a young
person to do to actually walk
through a door because anytime you walk
through a door you're effectively
closing doors behind you
and so you know when i chose to kind of
go the earlier stage route
out of banking and go to nea rather than
taking the you know mega fund private
equity route at like a tpg or silver
lake
was kind of like i'm never going to end
up there now
and i had to sit with that decision be
like okay you know what that's okay
because like you know this is what i
feel
and i feel this for good reasons and i
want to work with earlier companies and
and this is the type of you know
organization i want to be a part of
and um that's been kind of a major theme
but at the end of the day
like you typically end up where it makes
sense anyway
uh even if the path isn't the most
obvious and and regardless
of how kind of like stressful it might
seem along the way
uh but usually things tend to work
themselves out in a way that
in hindsight makes a lot of sense so
early stage growth equity versus private
equity walk me through a little bit
about your thoughts
as to why you specifically were
passionate about
going more of the early round rather
than the private route
yeah so um a lot of the people that had
worked in my office
at morgan stanley before i did had gone
to frankly to tpg there's a lot of
morgan stanley alumni at the tpg office
in san francisco
and um that was kind of like the the
thing to do
and it's an amazing team and they do
amazing stuff and they've
they've uh they've continued to be
extremely successful and one of the
things i realized was that when i looked
at
their day-to-day and the macro of what
they were doing it actually
lacked some of the things i liked about
banking and
it's very easy banking was really tough
i mean it's
tough for most people was extremely
tough for me um it's very easy to be
like oh i didn't like any part of it but
there were parts of it that i really did
like and i think that
there started to be a pattern that the
things that i liked were
i liked working on several things that
were related but different all at the
same time
and i liked having milestones very
quickly
so you know working on an ipo
that you know 10 months later is public
and working on an m a deal that in three
months gets announced and it's a public
to public m
a deal um you know it actually was kind
of like studying mechanical engineering
in some ways too where
in my first year at morgan stanley i did
a
software company m a deal an internet
company ipo any semiconductor debt deal
and it was kind of like when i was at
stanford study mechanical engineering
where i was taking
solid mechanics heat transfer and you
know a design course
all at the same time and they're all
related and you all take things
from each other but you know it's it's
fast-paced
it's it's a lot of learning and you kind
of get to see the connections between
these things and so
for me that was a like a a major theme
of what i wanted in my next job
and again zoom forward i guess like
eight years now
um actually eight nine years ago was
when i was interviewing at nea and other
firms
uh and i was able to realize that and
sure enough that's really still
how my brain works and what i like doing
now is a lot of different things that
are all
loosely related to each other um and and
really
getting those i feel like i like the
interim milestones i like
announcing deals i like making stuff
happen so
yeah it may have happened a lot of loose
loosely tied ideas that are coming in
together to something greater than that
and what i what i'm particularly also
curious about then is you know your
decision to take
to take six months join a yeshiva in
israel you know a lot of people you know
out of the army where i'm
you know my trajectory you know we go to
on these like six months the year-long
trips around the world
to experience to to to learn different
things especially about ourselves so you
took a different type of trip and you
did that you know
in the middle of your career literally
as you're booming as you're getting
all these up all these crazy
opportunities you take a step back and
and you go
again to study something a little bit
different so tell me about that
experience
absolutely so um so like i said i drew
up
you know i grew up with the grandparents
who were holocaust survivors always grew
up
feeling very jewish but not doing a lot
of kind of
practical stuff you know the the
passover the hanukkah
rosh hashanah yom kippur but always had
a lot of jewish pride when i got to
stanford i actually got more involved in
jewish stuff which is kind of the case i
think with most
american kids that go to college they
get just more involved in things that
they have affinity towards
um started going to shabbat dinners and
um and then moved to washington dc and
really started
connecting a lot more with with jewish
learning and was on a
trajectory um and uh
so after two years at nea i had an
amazing two years at nea
i got there when we were in the middle
of fun 14 which was a
we deployed very aggressively into some
amazing companies
we had a very small team i did 10 deals
in my first year i think
at nea um series a b and c
you know enterprise software and worked
mostly with two different people uh one
was uh was a guy named peter barris and
another
named harry weller and they were just
fantastic mentors
uh i would work on deals with them join
boards with them and got to just listen
and pick their brain and try to
understand based on their decades of
wisdom why they were doing what they're
doing which was like the greatest
experience you could ask for
and i'll never forget i was actually it
was june of 2015
and uh i was actually headed out to an
event and i had an uber
waiting for me downstairs and i was
walking by harry's office
and he said oh do you have a second i
said yeah sure like you know let's chat
and he was like look
you've been here for two years you know
we really like you we want you to stay
um i was like that's amazing i love it
here i'm learning a lot it's fantastic
you know these
the people are impressive and they're
good people and um
you know he said but hey you know if you
want to go to business school great
we'll send you business school you want
to go work at a portfolio company
you know great we'll set that up said
you know i said hey how about uh
going and taking six months going to
israel learning in yeshiva
and he said you know what's yeshiva and
uh
you know it was a really interesting
process then of
kind of explaining why this time away
and
the ability to take time for myself to
do some introspection after you know
high school which is intense and college
is intense and banking is super intense
and then
two years at nea where i was on a plane
or a train basically every week and
running around
just to take some time and understand
okay let's take stock who am i
you know where am i going what what do i
really care about
um and harry and peter were just
incredibly supportive of that idea and
they i give them
an amazing amount of credit for making
that happen
um even at times there was one moment
i'll never forget and i actually wrote
unfortunately uh tragically harry passed
away
a few months after i left nea and moved
to israel
um but uh and i wrote about him
and uh you know there was a point where
i was getting very nervous about leaving
one of the rules like you get a seat in
venture don't give up your seat
because you don't know if it'll be there
and you get back and i was very getting
very nervous and
harry comes by my office i say oh harry
with this thing and like i'll still go
to the board meeting and
he just says to me he says like shut up
you are going to yeshiva do not speak to
me again until you book your flight
and it was just such a you know i'm so
grateful to have such a
such an amazing mentor and guide and
such a clear signal
and and i went to yeshiva for six months
i was in in jerusalem and yeshiva called
makon
for guys like me and uh
um went back to nea very smoothly and
a month in harry comes over to me and
says you know
i want to know what you did over there
because whatever it was
it worked you got what i wanted you to
get out of the experience
whoa um and it and it was amazing and
you know i frankly i came back with an
itch
uh to come to israel and harry knew i
had that itch and the opportunity popped
up
and in late 2016 i
got on an airplane and made aliyah and
uh
been here been here since unbelievable
i just love that what did you learn in
the shiva what did you experience
something it's so unique that so few
get experienced so few in israel you get
to experience right i mean say
it's a very it's a very different type
of of
learning and experiential being so tell
me i i really i'm curious about what it
really is like and
how did that what did harry see in you
after those six months
that made him reflect back about your
experience
yeah so i think there's a there's
there's a few things i i'm
i don't want to take anything away from
the fact that just like being able to
step away and and get away from the
stress of work and the hustle
and just having that space is important
um but to really
kind of move forward rather than just
kind of like hunker down and
you know go sit on a beach somewhere
which is what my dad suggested i do
uh um you know what what was the
difference
and you know i i had the great
opportunity of going to this yeshiva
called macho
which is run by and filled with people
who have similar backgrounds to myself
and um i'm trying to think of the most
concise way to explain this
but there's an emphasis on
kind of again personal growth and an
openness
and i think i i read a book in my first
year in yeshiva
called mindset by carol dweck who's
actually a professor at
stanford and she walks through in a very
practical way the growth mindset versus
the fixed mindset and i think that
coming from the
from prep school to stanford to
investment banking
um you know you really get trained in
the fixed mindset
and it becomes hardwired and it's you
can read her book
and say yeah obviously the growth
mindset is better but
to really shift your mindset you need
an environment that fosters that and i
think that
being in a yeshiva where open
conversation surrounded by people who
have all made the same
or similar choice that i have to step
away from whatever they were doing
take the time come to israel want to
work on themselves
and then have the the resources of an
amazing set of rabbis and obviously an
incredible
you you know you have like cheat codes
for life in
in the gemara and in in musser and
in in in homash and uh it you know it's
just
and then coming back to nea what i think
what harry saw was
i had a higher level of clarity a higher
level of
understanding and thoughtfulness and i
was able to communicate
uh a lot more effectively what i had
going on in my head i was
able to parse through complicated things
in a more effective way
i i love that and i think that at the
end then that's what we all strive for
right i think that
now i remember when i was introduced to
muslims pyramid of needs
back in ninth grade i remember looking i
was like wow this is
awesome like at the end none of it
matters it's all about that fulfillment
it's all about that personal
you know feeling that that we've reached
that milestone that we're content that
at the end what everybody wants is to
just you know
have a good night's sleep and feel good
about their life and feel happy about
the good that they're doing for others
and and it sounds to me like that
experience is something that that just
helped to reach that
that goal right it wasn't centered
around your professionalism
or or your ability to make better
investments but it was about the ability
for you to harness you know
the different adversities that are going
on and different things that are
important to you and that clarity
which is something that i'm very
intentional about and something that i
focus on
and so i just love that i just love that
experience in that example
very inspiring yeah yeah it's it's
amazing you i still remember the first
time i did any kind of real torah class
after
hebrew school which is kind of a joke
but you know i was at
stanford with rabbi came in and we did
this maimonides class and i remember
being 20 years old
and taking uh you know the kind of like
basics of
of rambam and thinking of myself at age
20 like wow
this is really relevant to my life as a
20 year old
like as a college sophomore who's
basically just a joker having a good
time doing problem sets you know
like wow this is really relevant and it
turns out that like there's real wisdom
there so
uh i love it yeah alex all of that leads
up to the fact that today you're doing
incredible work in in so many different
tech ecosystems and
and i'm inspired by by saying you work
with the different companies you're
either investing advising or both in
in multitude of companies that i just
love and respect and so
i i i i think we need to do another
episode
just on that but i was just inspired to
hear about your life journey and 20
minutes go by so fast
so thank you very much for giving your
time thank you for uh
for sharing with me your journey and and
and i can't wait to hear the next part
in the next episode
yeah absolutely i'll give you i'll give
you 30 seconds on what i'm doing now
um which is you know the truth is and i
developed this when i was at any i just
love working with companies
frankly the earlier the better um i've
been the great beneficiary of being in
front of a lot of successful
entrepreneurs learning a lot and being a
kind of collection vessel for a lot of
that wisdom
and that's what i try to share with all
my companies and uh and what i try to
bring and if i'm an advisor or an
investor or
or whatever it may be that's just that's
what i love doing
i love it alex thank you so so much the
last question the most important one
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
um okay so i think that
uh you know you have to think about
what's aspirational versus what's like
what other people would say
um i think one thing that comes to mind
is probably quantitative
i'm definitely a numbers guy i try to
bring numbers to things that don't uh
don't naturally espouse that um
the other thing i would say is that i'm
i'm fun i try to have a good time with
what i'm doing
even if other people are like really you
like spreadsheets that much um
and uh and then
i i try to do fun with a lot more than
spreadsheets and then i guess i would
say
people would say that i'm uh i'm direct
i just i kind of get straight to it
um try to be efficient and uh in that
way so
i love him i love it alex thank you very
much and
your time i can't wait to just come and
see you in jerusalem and
and thank you for taking that to us
absolutely thanks so much
you